one of the biggest effects of climate
change our planet is losing its ice
scientists say the ice losses fueled by
global warming now total more than 1.2
trillion tons a year a recent u.n
climate report says ice sheet and
glacier melt are the main contributors
to rising sea levels that threaten the
swamp coastal cities senior national and
environmental correspondent that's been
tracy has visited iceland where ice
covers 10 percent of the country but now
that country is rapidly losing all of
its glaciers
so this is your office it is this is
amazing i love my office
i would too
we met glaciologist m jackson on top of
one of her favorite places in the world
let's talk about this giant piece of ice
we're standing on yeah
what is this called so we're on the
glacier breath america yogurt right this
is iceland's third largest glacier and
it flows right off of the vatican ice
cap that's the largest glacier mass in
europe more than half a mile thick in
some parts
it is now dissolving before our eyes
how quickly is this melting it's roughly
around 450 feet per year that whole
expanse was that all the glacier at one
point
absolutely everything between where we
are and the north atlantic ocean that
was all covered with ice
and that glacier is gone now so if you
want to know what the future looks like
just look right there
getting to this glacier now requires a
30-minute hike over dry land that just a
few years ago was covered in ice
jackson who lives in oregon has been
studying iceland's glaciers for more
than a decade
what exactly is happening here on
iceland there's roughly 400 glaciers on
this island and the majority of them are
melting at rates never before seen in
human history this island is losing its
ice every time i come back to this
glacier i don't believe my eyes and i am
watching them dissolve i'm watching them
die right in front of me
and to see that she took us inside this
ice cave the pattern that the ice makes
it's so cool to show us what is
essentially the melting glaciers
plumbing system all that water has to go
somewhere and it makes these tubes so we
see these tubes are bigger than they've
ever been before to transport all that
water these tubes would naturally happen
but the scale of them is unnatural and
that's because of human-caused climate
change ice all over the planet is
rapidly melting
scientists say all that water rushing
into the world's oceans is not only
making sea levels rise but could also be
changing the ocean circulation and
fueling more extreme weather events such
as hurricanes and heat waves
m jackson and her fellow researchers
have launched a unique effort to bring
attention to the very real possibility
that iceland could lose nearly all of
its ice in the next 100 years driven to
witness the ice before it's gone
they produced a short film called after
ice using historical photos paired with
new drone footage to show the rapid
retreat of the island's glaciers
[Music]
what we are witnessing here is
an event that we've never seen before
glacier researcher thori arenson is part
of the team behind the film what do you
want people to take away from that when
they see it an idea of hope
an idea of resistance it's sad to see
all of this beauty being devastated but
we have to say
i'm not going to allow this to continue
indefinitely
iceland held a glacier funeral back in
2019 after a 700 year old sheet of ice
shrunk so much it was essentially
declared dead by scientists
iceland has now lost so much ice that
with less weight from the glaciers the
land is rising that's making some
harbors shallower and harder for boats
to navigate
and scientists are also worried about
more volcanic eruptions as the ground
here becomes increasingly unstable
without glaciers holding it in place
ready to go find some icebergs
before we left m jackson wanted us to
see one more thing this place she calls
a glacial graveyard
this is broken down bits of glaciers
that have been here for centuries
we paddled through a paradox
you are watching total collapse
a lagoon of beautiful destruction
so a couple of decades ago could we have
done this could we have been paddling
through here
not a couple decades ago when i first
started my field work out here 12 11
years ago i walked from land to ice but
now i take a boat to get to these
glaciers the change is that quick
but she has not lost hope she says we
can still keep the planet from
overheating and give the glaciers a
chance to grow we're losing ice and
we're going to lose a lot more ice but
that does not mean that ice is gone
forever on the planet ice can grow back
but that means you and i have to act now
i want people to think about the future
with ice
and that's what i fight for
for cbs morning's ben tracy in iceland
so they put it out there and they want
us to do what you said because we look
at it you think we all lament it
now what to do about it this is not
about saving the ice it's about saving
us it's not about saving the planet it's
about saving us it's about a a home for
our children and what people can do is
vote so collectively we as a people as a
planet can enact policies that slow
global warming or
take a really big risk for those that
are familiar with that area it's it hits
differently because it hits home yeah
and unfortunately for us it takes that
sometimes for it to actually hit home
for us to realize how serious i mean you
want to talk about home glacier national
park here in the united states is going
to run out of glaciers also no more ice
by the end of this century according to
federal scientists so
it's an issue yeah i didn't like ben's
phrase beautiful destruction was
beautiful and
you don't want to see us lose that no
you don't